for the class of 2023 it's hard not to
get caught up in the excitement and
thrill of graduation day but ask these
grads what's next and you'll likely hear
a range of responses what's next for you
guys taking a nice long vacation and
then starting work at a bank I'm looking
for jobs right now I know it's like peak
season for graduates I am doing civil
engineering there's a lot of demand the
job market is really hard now that's
because this year's class is entering a
bumpy labor market after starting
College in Fall 2019 just months before
the pandemic hit according to LinkedIn
hiring overall is down 29 since April
2022 while hiring for entry-level jobs
requiring a college degree has dropped
nearly 32 percent